DIRECTV's fantasy zone senior fantasy
football analyst analyst analyst not
expert now I'm an expert but that's not
my title that I took the dissertation
for you every week we go over it senior
fantasy football analyst analyst and
you've got a podcast fantasy football
the fantasy football follies what does
that mean it means I break down my
winning picks week by week and I'll tell
you something no no no no rich we could
laugh we could joke I listen I want a
qualifying tournament not once last week
but - okay I'm going to I'm going
through that I'm going to the Big Dance
okay I'm not playing around if you if
you want to win okay listen to the
fantasy football follies it's it's not a
joke like I don't take myself seriously
hey and I don't do it for the money I do
it for the honey but the fact of the
matter is is I won not one Brockman will
tell you I want two qualifying
tournament it means I'm out there
playing on draftkings I'm destroying
people I'm likes warding people I'm
kicking people i won
not one but two in one weekend so listen
to the fantasy football following it's a
culture of winning it's a car side
barstool sports it's on iTunes it's
everywhere you need to listen
they got bootleg copies down the street
okay trust me it's a culture of winning
so give me give me your best to give me
your best for the weekend give me give
me the tip give me the tip that that the
senior fantasy football I'll tell us
I'll tell you who's gonna kick ass this
weekend he hasn't had too many great
games you talked about he sounded like
he was underwater they're underground
Travis Kelce yeah well Kelsey I think at
that big beer that's what I think he was
just shoving anything up is he paying
them a lot of money right ticket Travis
I'm a fan get a real cell phone plan get
yourself a real cell phone in a real
cell phone plan it's not the beer you
were being you were being polite by
saying that's the beard
so you think Kelsey's gonna have a big
Monday night big Monday night of versus
Washington because even the Raiders who
look like doodoo last week yeah their
tight end got off this last night Cook
was getting some catches yeah they're
they're they're their numbers they've
allowed 250 receiving yards V versatile
ends this season I look
my notes because I want to get it right
but if you want to just listen to me you
want to have look at my desk Travis
Kelce this we converse the Washington
red see he's gonna kill it he's gonna be
an expert you gotta say Kelsey
if you're gonna be a tight end a
professional tighter an all-star tenon
you should get a cellphone plan so it
works both ways
I mean the fact that you even let this
guy talk on the show you were being
really polite if I had heard it was that
kind of cell phone reception you know
hung up on me I'm live radio and
television he's gonna get off you know
who's not getting off who anybody with
the Oakland Raiders this is not a
revenge game the no-fly zone and I'll
tell you one thing I love him as a
player I love him as a personality I
love him as a story Marshawn Lynch is
not fantasy football beast mode he's
exciting every time he gets the ball
right but the numbers are match up and
they're just they're not gonna get
better well I want to put a pin in that
conversation for your next segment
because I have some thoughts
fantasy football related thoughts on the
Raiders and the Broncos as well and I
know you're like you don't want to
believe the hype on a lot of those
Raiders boom and I have a couple of
cents to add on that subject oh please
do for the moment though I need you to
help me with this showcase we're
celebrating our third anniversary in a
couple of weeks right mmm next week I'm
sober six okay
so we're celebrating our third year
anniversary one of the first segments we
ever did yes was let's decide let's look
at the schedule yeah let's look at the
docket of NFL games and pick some games
that nobody's thinks is a marquee game
but we think it's gonna be a good game
we called them sneaky good game sneaky
good game is there anything incorrect
about this set up okay
okay things happen you might not expect
okay so last week one of the sneaky good
games that Chris Brockman said yes was
gonna be a sneaky good game of week
number three was dolphins at Jets yeah
thank you good game not a sneaky good
game turned out to be awful really bad
but the fact that the Jets were the ones
in a blowout victory but not the
Dolphins unexpected has caused Chris
Brockman to say that was a sneaky good
call so so so basically you'll
rationalize this segment being good any
which way you can that's
he's attempting to do when I'm saying
though credits to win last week Nikki
good game no I didn't take the Jets to
win last week and I'll tell you
something
as far as fantasy and NFL stats that
touchdown that Jay Cutler got would
six-second take it off any sort of books
if you own him in fantasy and you
benefited from that shame on you
that was the whole thing was disgusting
it happens man it happened but you were
the segment isn't let's pick an upset
winner no that's Elvis but God that is
sneaky good because look jet fans I
imagine we're pretty happy with the
turnout last week and they had every
reason going into the game to not feel
good about it and so therefore it ended
up good is good and sneaky game it
sneaky good games yes good as part of
sneaky good games listen you could
rationalize this however you want if
you're gonna say that that was a sneaky
good game for a small amount of Jets
fans that are hanging on for dear life
so be it Brockman now but here's there
were a lot of good games last week so it
was slim pickins for sneaky good games
don't don't complain don't complain I'm
complaining he's better I'm just just be
better just as a perfect example a
better one of the that but this wasn't
available to be chosen as a sneaky good
game Rams Niners no you could say that
was a sneaky good game yeah that wasn't
a sneaky good game I was a sneaky
excellent that was a sneaky one of the
best games of the year okay but going
going into the game you know one thought
that that was gonna be a question job
that's your job
that's what sneaky telling you that's
your job so listen to me okay but that's
your job you didn't you didn't get it
last week that's your job hit the drop
hit the drop
there's Chris Brockman with sneaky good
games contest likely to surprise you or
their heretofore
competitive how about that that's Tom
Brokaw lending his voice and his uh his
gravitas to sneaky good games go for it
play the music and you've got three
sneaky good games right now last week
one of my sneaky good games was the
London game and by the way a result not
everyone saw coming which made it good
going back to London for Saints dolphins
ok yeah Saints have a chance to right
the ship get back to 500 dolphins are 1
and 1 the Saints are 3 point favorites
here they put up 34 points last week
against a team that lost to the freakin
Jets okay so weird things happen in
London Willy Sneed is back
the dolphin during a rough road stretch
la New York now London I like this to be
sneaky good I'd like this to be a sneaky
good game and I'm too already letting
the game day morning folks know I'm
choosing the Dolphins to win this one
the Miami Dolphins are gonna win this
football game how's that gonna happen
they are going to start the game they're
going to play it mm-hm and they are a
much better team than what we saw in New
York last week I think that they are
gonna be very good in London I agree
with that being a sneaky good game
choice I think that could be a sneaky
good game shootout choice what are your
other two oh and three Giants at the one
in what bucks now here's the deal I
don't know if the Bucks are as good as
we all thought they were when the season
started Jameis Winston you know when I
squint my eyes a little bit sort of
looks like Josh Freeman back there and I
think the Giants get their first win of
the year sneaky good oh okay what's your
third one third one someone has to win
it's the Battle of Ohio we got Owen
three Cincinnati against Owen three
crown your toss someone has to win Andy
Dalton by the way is not as bad as he's
playing right now Bengals get their
first win
vantes Burfict is back miles Garrett
maybe but you know who leads the league
in interceptions thrown this year the
Shawn Kaiser I picked up the Cincinnati
Bengals defense now but again
this is what a sneaky good games about
nobody thinks this is gonna be a good
game and and this is gonna be a tight
contest where it's gonna be in doubt
with minutes to go that's what a sneaky
the segment is I reinvented it the
Battle of Ohio now is is is the winner
of the Battle of Ohio like that's kind
of like being the king of Akron it's
like kind of like it just it's like just
that like anybody could do it you'll get
to hang with LeBron okay cool
and he doesn't care about either one of
those teams you did the cell phone oint
the king of of Akron doesn't even care
about the Battle of Ohio but I do agree
that could be a good game he's a Cowboys
fan it's acronym listen this Kelce is
from Akron blame it on the New York City
public school education system I am a
product slips through the cracks of the
New York City public school education
since back in 60 seconds with the senior
fantasy football analyst of DIRECTV
fantasy zone Michael Rapaport will talk
about that Raiders Broncos game when we
come back
okay so you already said Travis Kelce is
gonna have a great week on Monday Night
Football
yeah who else do you like this week Dez
it's a play finally he's out of a you
know death role lineups he'll have a
better matchup this week first the Rams
play him he's gonna do well yeah that's
right he had Jackrabbit Jenkins week one
and then he had the no-fly zone and week
two yes and then obviously week three
Patrick Peterson and the rest of the
group how about that touchdown he scored
Monday night we carried seven people
across good play tough play was awesome
and there was a Dez Bryant play it
wasn't desperate and I think the the
Cowboys are gonna get on a roll
unfortunate saying it because the New
York Giants have a less wins than the
New York Jets that's unbelievable
that is unbelievable yes so you like Dez
you like Travis Kelce I like Dre but but
but the don't believe the hype is is
where okay you stay away from every
single person and I have them and I love
them and it pains me to say Amari Cooper
cuz I love him but there's no feelings
in fantasy don't do it do not do it I
will tell you our team in our league
that we're in together yes and change
Folgers of the ether we have Derek Carr
and Amari Cooper Amari Cooper has 101
receiving yards on the season I know on
the season 10 catches for 101 yards it
has been mystifying Crabtree's been
getting everything in terms of targets
catches touchdowns a kid totally Aqib
Talib lashes snatched his chain off his
neck so this is not a good matchup we
are on our on our fantasy benching Amari
Cooper mm-hmm I went and had it last
night Brockman I think I texted you this
I picked up Trevor Simeon we're playing
him instead of Derek Carr in this game I
have no problem with however what you
said in the last segment about Marshawn
Lynch not a good fantasy football beast
mode I understand that but last year
with latavius Murray and the rest of
that offensive line they ran the same
run and play against this Denver Broncos
team ten times in a row and just jammed
it down their throat okay so they have
beast mode back there I think this week
may be the week that you see that beast
being fed 2025 carries okay got his sea
legs under him three games now this is
his fourth week
back in the mix that would be the way
for the Raiders to win this fight I like
that I like that would be the way to fer
for them to win the game if they're
gonna give him the ball like that but
the Raiders don't they have football
like that and haven't but they might not
try to force it this weekend throw the
ball because they ain't throwing
anything and Derek Carr and I love Derek
Carr it's under pressure not good when
he's under pressure he is not a good
quarterback and it was proven last week
when that pocket isn't clean tough and
and Amari and is it Crabtree's not even
uh I know he might not even be there
which makes Leeds but when I saw that I
led me to believe him I might be crazy
to bench Amari Cooper because this could
be the week Diddy is a breakout but not
in this matchup against the no-fly zone
I don't like it at all I don't like it
and I so I'm taking your advice and I'm
benched car and I'm benching Cooper and
I'm seeing how that goes who else what
are the hype do you know Melvin Gordon
versus the Eagles Melvin Ely yup don't
do it hey guy they got it don't do it
just listen I don't have to sit here
explaining the numbers I'm just saying
I'll be back next Friday and say I told
yourself that's what I'm gonna say I
told you the first two weeks don't mess
around with des this week of saying mess
around with des I don't want to get into
the numbers and the highfalutin stuff
just saying don't don't do it don't do
don't believe the hype okay so that
would take some serious call but we
benched Jordan Howard last night against
the against the Packers and by the way
by the way by the way we did not see
coming that grind-it-out
nine minute drive down 28 did you see
that last night but I have a question
yes I feel like I come here to give the
listeners and viewers of the show advice
make it personal no but I thing that I
feel like is like I'm executive
producing your team that I'm competing
against and I don't like it
using my information my think tank to
help your team benefit playing against
me inevitably and I don't like it I'm
here for the people rich I understand
I'm not here to help you in Brockman I
can't put earmuffs on what you sitting
next I'm just saying but I'm giving you
this information then you're like you're
transferring over to Brockman like it
came out of your think tank it's came in
out of this think tank you know Brockman
I think if we had Melvin Gordon we
should have benched him today yeah I
think they're bright I mean you know
traditionally yeah you know I'd be
careful of Le'Veon Bell and
tonio Brown particularly Antonio Brown
versus the Ravens now they looked
pathetic last week in London they
weren't in London last week they're in
Chicago the Raven the Ravens okay
the Ravens see I can't follow you said
levy on bail and Antonio Brown and they
were bad last week they're playing the
Ravens at the Ravens I'm saying the
reason why I'm saying you should you
should watch out for those guys this is
because they're playing the Raven on it
I expect they got some sleep and they're
they're gonna they're they need to have
some some sort of respect because Blake
bortles look like I don't know Dan
Marino Terry Bradshaw it's funny you
know what do we say on Monday that uh
Blake bortles he's done so well in
London he's like the Jerry Lewis of
quarterbacking there's a funny people in
Paris they only know about Jerry Lewis
we had a lot of it Blake bortles they
think he's the greatest quarterback of
all that's funny he's like he's like did
like the prototyping on a stamp over
there
he's the Montana yeah well today he
plays for them this this week the Ravens
defense is gonna bounce back Antonio and
levy on I'm not saying don't start him
but in daily especially watch out for
Antonio Brown his numbers are
traditionally down and been the guy who
throws and Tony the ball yeah somehow
some way he stinks on the road I'm
telling you I was toying with the idea
and I'm still toying with the idea here
I'm telling you I think I might choose
the Ravens to win this game period on
the game day morning on Sunday I
suggested it can you just at least give
me some credit have we now he mentioned
it a couple days ago when I didn't see
it on the air watch the show all day
every day
so the videotape when it's a court
degree let's go to the videotape shout
out to the great New York City broadcast
he's got to be in the Hall of Fame
Warner wolf Warner wolf his best thing
would always be like if if somebody won
by 47 points and he'd say if you had
that team in 48 points you lost he was
the best man you'd Warner wolf I
remember I grew up watching him
Warner wolf let's go to the videotape
now there's no such thing anymore before
I let you go what did you think of the
Carmelo trade from the Knicks to be
honest I think I'm glad it's over
I'm glad the whole thing is over I'm
glad it's just not gonna be talked about
anymore it's frustrating as I think
Carmelo is is a player
he was done wrong by the Knicks from
Phil Jackson I think it was
disrespectful from the beginning to end
and I'm glad he's in a better situation
I'm so frustrated with the Knicks
they got Michael Beasley running around
like this is this is like a circus act
Michael Beasley is making predictions
about the team and how good he is and
then he's arguing about ten percent of
the brain this is like a freak show we
have at the garden so to answer your
question I'm glad he's gone good for him
the the state of the NBA is concerning
to me all these teams hard and in cp3
and Russell Westbrook who by the way
hasn't signed his extension and let me
tell you something James Harden left OKC
Kevin Durant left OKC
shaved Russell Westbrook uh-uh hasn't
signed as an extension there's something
about OKC that's not right and and KD
took the brunt of that and I don't think
it's fair and by the way I have no
problem with KD he just followed the
LeBron James playbook but there's
something about OKC that people just
they don't commit right away too
well I mean with Paul George could walk
obviously oh he's not staying there well
I mean unless that what if the three of
them start actually you know coalescing
in 45 games a win Cobb 45 games calm 45
they'll be competitive 45 games I gotta
take the over on that 45 games 45 games
it's not just easy you know look at like
the Miami Heat
when they first did this big three thing
it doesn't just like click you know how
he's gonna work right it's not just wait
five games they're not playing on paper
45 game Wayne Wade's now with LeBron God
it's the whole thing's is a mess man the
whole thing they're a good team no well
look I mean they've got they were able t
they were able to hold on to Kevin Love
they signed Derrick Rose they still have
the rest of their core Kyle Korver is
like the 11th best player on that team
they've got they now have obviously
doing Wayne Wade and who could forget
the king of Akron himself LeBron James
self anointed king of Akron I don't know
why you want to be like the king no
disrespect to the great there's no such
places Akram Quinn Akron yeah
there's a lot of effort like a lot of
brain like like you know membrane that's
the guy from Akron king of Akron how
many names did I say one on the show
good it's all good it's all good love
having you on brother I'm glad to be
here one more time pop your pod what do
you got oh the podcast a fantasy
football follies fantasy football
follies there you go it's a culture of
winning and check them out as always on
DIRECTV's fantasy zone this Sunday all
Dan'l 704 on DirecTV the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint